foreign
I'm so glad you're here with us today
thank you Stephanie it is great to be
here
at Vimeo you lead a Workforce of 1300
people worldwide you have creatives you
have financed people you have
technologists so I'm going to start with
a really easy question what was it like
to manage this diverse Workforce through
a global pandemic a racial Reckoning and
a very fraught return to office oh it
was a brief Stephanie now um it was
really challenging
um and I think
the only constant has been changed and
as a leader you obviously you have a
Workforce that's looking for certainty
and they're looking to control what's
happening around them and I think what
we all found as Leaders no matter what
company you were you were you were in
responsible for was that you couldn't
offer certainty and you couldn't always
control the environment and the things
around you and so you know for for me it
was really about
agility how do we stay flexible as a
team how do we communicate in real time
and keep people informed as we try and
move through things
um and then also just how do we lead
with more Humanity
um you know for Vimeo one of the things
I've really learned over the last few
years is we each experience the world so
differently
uh we have employees who are remote we
have an incredible team in Ukraine these
are people who have employees are on the
front lines who are literally at War on
the other hand you have people you know
in different parts of the world who are
experiencing mental health challenges or
burnout uh and so I think it was really
just
the hardest part was not being able to
give everyone certainty not being able
to just apply a one-size-fits-all rule
for everyone
but I ultimately think it forced us as a
company to build more trust because to
be agile and flexible and to lead with
Humanity you have to trust each other
and so I'm sort of optimistic that
actually we're emerging from this time
with a culture that is more flexible and
Nimble and also hopefully has more trust
yeah can you give an example of
something that you put into place
perhaps during the pandemic to enhance
Communications or build trust or you
know create a greater sense of community
or even to communicate that there is no
certainty that is a muscle that you
think you'll continue to use in the
organization far into the future yeah
there's a a couple things that we did
you know one and we are a video platform
so I obviously have to talk about video
but I mean this sincerely
one of the hardest parts when you're all
sort of disparate is you lose context
and you lose Nuance when you communicate
and we did make a concerted effort to
move away from email and chat text-based
communication as much as possible and
actually try particularly for our
leadership team when we were
communicating to do it with your face
and your hands and your body and your
emotions and we did that through live
streaming a lot of communications
recording a lot of videos we sent
asynchronous video messages so I send
like I record my screen and just send a
note out to people every new hires you
know does a video to welcome and
introduce themselves
um a lot of our meetings we've actually
replaced with just quick video
presentations and and actually what what
that really did was allow the humanity
to kind the context to come through and
I think that helped us a lot kind of
stay close
um so that was one I think really
important thing another important thing
is I think just creating mechanisms to
make it easier to talk about when things
aren't working because a critical part
of being agile is recognizing we have an
area that isn't working and so one of
the things that we do at Vimeo is we try
I do this in all of my town halls we do
in a lot of meetings is always talk
about what's working what our top three
things and what isn't working yet and
we've kind of created I think a
framework that sort of takes a stigma
away from talking about what's not
working and when you make that
normalized and comfortable for people I
feel like it's allowed us to be more
open as an organization about what do we
need to change what do we need to Pivot
and both of those you know sort of being
more video first in our communication
and being more transparent and
normalizing what's not working I think
because this has been really helpful and
certainly something we're carrying
forward I love that advice about being
video first so many of our members of
our Workforce live in video world
they're used to video as a means of
communication which brings me to my next
question you've talked about how the
organization has changed how do you see
the workforce changing what is different
with the young Millennials and even now
the first wave of gen Z coming into the
workplace oh I think it's incredibly
different and you know one of the things
that we think about at Vimeo a lot is a
lot of the
mechanisms and communication modes that
we still use today that really
Antiquated they were designed for a
totally different environment and a
totally different generation
but I see a lot of differences one of
them I think is the line between your
personal life and work life is is
definitely blending and we're used to if
you think about your personal life look
at Tick Tock like
we're our this generation is used to
consuming content learning engaging in a
very specific way and if they then have
to come to work and to be trained on a
job read a 300 page manual like it's not
going to happen right or if you miss the
meeting and you have to watch the zoom
recording of a three-hour meeting that's
just not going to happen and so I think
that there is definitely sort of this we
talk about the consumerization of
Enterprise and those are just fancy
words for saying the way that the things
that way we communicate and interact in
our personal lives is going to translate
to work and so I definitely think that's
a that's an area of opportunity the
other thing I see from sort of the the
the generation that the newest
generation coming into the workforce is
sort of of course Mission driven but I
think there's a desire to really
understand the why behind things and
um one of our sort of communication
mantras is we we never we never talk
about the what without the why uh and I
think there's just a desire to you know
the idea of like well there's a
hierarchy or you know my boss told me
that this is what we're gonna do or you
know that I think is increasingly moving
away and people they don't want to just
do something because someone with a sort
of formal Authority told them to do it
they want to do it because they
understand why it matters why it ties to
the mission
um and I think that that forces you know
leaders to really bring more of the why
into how we communicate and motivate
people so those are those are two of the
things I see and then you know the third
I think is just flexibility right I
think um and this is true of all of us
but particularly the younger generation
I think they're looking for flexibility
uh and they want options and choices and
you know it's not always easy and
feasible to provide ultimate flexibility
but this is where I try and Orient it
more to agility it's like how can we
have approaches and principles and and
and be committed to things but also know
when to question and when to actually
pivot yeah
Anjali can you share a few examples of
ways that you at Vimeo have tried to
really be proactive when it comes to
addressing or understanding what your
next generation of employees are going
to want either in terms of
purpose or in terms of benefits or in
terms of flexibility are there programs
or processes you've put in place that
really speak to this big sea change
we're seeing in terms of values from uh
from the workforce firstly of course
it's all about listening right and I
think like many organizations the way
we've tried to listen and understand our
Workforce is it's very similar it's you
know q and A's and
um and engagement surveys and and things
like that and
um some of the things that we've done
you know we have a people and culture
NPS sort of net promoter score the same
way we have for our users for our
internal teams
um but but I would say one of the things
that we've really tried to do is
appreciate that when we get inputs from
our employees 1300 employees ever it's
it's you can't look at the averages you
can't look at it all in totality and try
and pull out like an obvious oh this is
how everybody's feeling because what you
actually when you really dig into it and
truly listen and do focus groups and
talk to people what you'll find is
actually there's very different
experiences and desires among your
employees and so um I think for us what
we've really just tried to do is have a
bunch of different listening mechanisms
and then resist the urge to like
conveniently pull like oh this is what
everyone's feeling let's just do this
thing as the action uh and it's hard and
we're still kind of figuring it out but
I will tell you some of the things that
we've heard from employees have changed
our approach to hybrid work or travel or
even things like our approach to
compensation or our Approach To Deni and
and so I think it's more just like I
said that agile listening like
constantly really understanding what's
happening but but not all not treating
everything as like an average or the
same and for us it's been particularly
Stark because we have offices and teams
in so many different countries and the
difference is they're substantial
they're really substantial about the way
we we solve different things and we used
to have a very sort of one Vimeo Global
approach in the name of consistency
unfairness and what we've found is we
have to be more localized we really do
we have to design mechanisms to support
our teams and in a very different way
because their experiences and the world
around them is quite different so I
think that that's you know that's
definitely been one and I will tell you
it has involved a lot of
um as an executive team and leadership
team it's involves a lot of trying
things it not working and changing them
and a great example is our is our q a I
feel like every leader I know has a
perspective on whether they do open q a
or Anonymous q a or real-time q a we've
changed our approach there multiple
times and I know we will again because
we're still figuring out the right way
to listen and have a dialogue with a
very diverse Workforce I want to stay on
um newcomers to the workplace for just
another moment because another thing I
hear from CEOs of my generation and an
older is a concern about making sure
that we are not just
um providing our our youngest employees
with the flexibility and the purpose
that they need but also the training and
the wisdom that comes oftentimes from
being in close proximity to a mentor or
to somebody who's done the job for many
more years what is your philosophy and
take on making sure that that knowledge
transfer is happening I think it's a
it's a major challenge that I don't know
that everyone you know we're sort of
have a solution for I think about that
all the time
um you know we have a very distributed
Workforce at Vimeo we have people in
over eight countries my executive team
is entirely distributed so I've really
realized the benefits of being able to
have a distributed Workforce and being
able to attract talent and just be more
inclusive on the flip side there's
definitely I think I think a lack of the
same kinds of learning opportunities and
mentorship particularly for the youngest
folks that are entering the workforce so
I think it's a challenge
one of the approaches that we've been
taking is and what's sort of nice is
we're modeling it at the top so if my
entire executive team is distributed
that means I have to learn how to
provide real-time feedback mentorship
and development for a whole set of new
Executives who've just joined my we have
sort of changed up the executive team
almost entirely in the last 12 months so
I've had to deal with the same
challenges and we've had to literally we
call it our operating system we've had
to design an operating system as an
executive team for how we're going to
work together in that environment how do
we share real-time feedback how do we
create sort of the right communication
loops and so I think from my perspective
it's more we have to be able to do it
ourselves and model it and then I think
it's it's a it's a more proven mechanism
for for young people I will say like
many companies we I do believe that
in-person collaboration is really
important for learning we do have you
know we bring people into an office if
you're remote we ask folks to come in
and spend time in a room with their team
do social activities all of those things
I don't think they will go away nor do I
think they should
um but you know candidly it's an area
that I don't think we've really figured
out perfectly and I think it's really
critical that as Leaders we do that so
that this next generation is is able to
get the same growth opportunities that
we all had
well and it's interesting you know the
tools that you mentioned at the very
beginning of our conversation around
video can be really helpful there I've
heard of a number of organizations that
have really encouraged their young
people to present as a way of you know
having to go out and find the
information they need and then because
we have video tools available to us now
you know they have an opportunity to
share their ideas with a large group of
people but first kind of going through
the fact finding in the research and
then sharing their ideas in an earlier
comment you talked a little bit about
mental wellness and you know the
different things that people are
bringing to work whether it is you know
exhaustion burnout during the black
lives matter protests we had a lot of
people coming to the office feeling
trauma and feeling you know really
personal issues bubble to the surface
I'm wondering if you can share a little
bit about how you deal with this
increasing
personal
um you know when people bring their
whole selves to the office which we
encourage sometimes they bring things
parts of themselves that are are
challenging yeah I mean you know I think
I've always thought you know it's the
responsibility of a leader is to empower
people to do their best work and
responsibility of a company is to
empower our people to do their best work
and so of course we have a real role to
play in supporting things like mental
health issues or burnout and you know
the way I think like many companies the
way we initially probably sought to do
that was more you know you're seeing a
problem and you're reacting by trying to
provide Mental Health Resources or
support or time off and I think an
empathy just empathy and I think that's
really important and I always say to so
many of our managers like just care if
we just care a lot of a lot of things
get easier you don't have to design a
hundred mechanisms if you just have the
right people in place who care
at the same time I will say what we're
realizing now in sort of this next phase
is that that's a reactive approach and
actually the root cause that we can
control at Vimeo the root cause of a lot
of stress and burnout
is sometimes people either don't have
enough we don't have enough Focus right
there's we're being asking people to do
too many things or they don't have they
don't feel like they're supported in
doing those things
um and and that I think is actually
where we we should be spending more time
is how do we actually set the right
prioritization and focus there's some
issue there right there's a root cause
there that's a oh I feel like I'm
stressed because there's too much going
on I don't feel equipped to solve it
then we should we should get into the
what is the detail there and do we need
to to do things differently and you know
one of our themes at Vimeo
um this year was do less better as the
economy starts to maybe move sideways do
you think that there are going to be
stakeholders who say you know out with
all of this touchy-feely you know the
workplace is a family stuff where are my
results absolutely I think the pendulum
has already swung pretty clearly I mean
I I work in SAS software as a service so
we we already went from the you know
growth at all cost to profitability you
know pendulum swing
um my my perspective on this and I it
hasn't changed you know I think
um I think the best leaders and cultures
deliver results
and treat people well
and I actually think if you treat people
well with kindness and empathy you will
get better results
and so you know for me I think what I I
observed over the last few years is
that part I think hasn't changed and
shouldn't change there were I think a
lot of times when companies we did
things because maybe it was lip service
or we felt pressured and that's not
going to be sustainable but that's not
what ultimately that's not what people
need in any case so you know I sort of
see it as
um as be the way you Channel how you are
caring towards your employees and how
you are empathetic always should be in
service of helping people do their best
work which will deliver results which
will be good for the bottom line and you
have to believe that and you have to be
committed to that and if you use that
consistently in your decision making it
should not be a trade-off these are not
mutually exclusive things honestly how
have you been taking care of yourself
during this period of tremendous turmoil
and change but also growth you mentioned
you just had a baby
there's a lot on your shoulders how as a
leader do you practice some self care or
how do you make sure that you're getting
the balance you need to be the most
effective leader you can be I think
um
recently the phrase I use a lot to
myself is is
two things can be true both both can be
true I say this a lot um and for me you
know I think of it as like this job is
hard and it's gotten harder you know
um we went public at the height of the
pandemic last year Market volatility has
been tremendous
um you know we we're obviously going
through a ton with people's pandemic we
have a team in Ukraine going through a
war all these things that have happened
and and so it's a hard job and it's an
incredibly privileged job it's a gift
right and so I think for me it's sort of
acknowledging both of those things has
helped me a lot
the way I've tried to to kind of lead
has been it's always been this way which
is for me it's I have to have passion
you know I have to have passion I have
to believe so deeply that What Vimeo is
doing is important and matters for the
world and if I have passion I have
energy and then I will you know I can
kind of move through anything
um I have to find joy in my team
you know I feel like especially in hard
times I look back at my career and
actually some of my my most fulfilling
times work were when in the hardest
business situations but it's because it
brought a group of people together all
in one team and so I think that's been
you know a really big part of it and
then yeah like you have to be a little
selfish sometimes and take care of
yourself and I am really fortunate I
think I have a great support network
around me
um and I do I am I always I would say my
husband and I have a deal where on
Sundays I disappear for a couple hours I
just disappear and I walk around the
city and I listen to my music and I do
whatever I need to do and that's really
important so you talked about how hybrid
work is going to look very different in
the future than how we describe it today
it's basically in office a couple days
work from home a couple of other days
tell us a little bit more about what you
could potentially see that evolving into
I mean I I think the idea of an office
as a time and place completely goes away
right and I think it's really going to
be people are going to want to work from
anywhere
anywhere in the world even the concept
of like where you're located is going to
change
um and then the idea of like I'm gonna
work on this time zone or I'm going to
attend this meeting that's scheduled on
this date I think that's going to go
away
and I think what you're going to find is
more and more work particularly from
knowledge workers is going to be done
anywhere anytime communication and
collaboration will happen asynchronously
and we will be using tools and
Technology whether it's video whether
it's AI to basically enable that at
scale among many people anywhere in the
world
um and then I think leadership leaders
are going to look different right
because I think it's going to require if
you think about the skill set to be a
you know Global CEO
30 years ago versus what what that will
require now I think in the future you're
going to have to be the skill sets going
to be like how do you communicate with
diverse you know Global audiences and
employees across time zones in a way
that is effective that provides context
and Alignment at scale
um how do you organize programs whether
it's compensation whether it's you know
training all of that is going to look
very different but I think the ultimate
thing you'll see is just this so there
were these constraints that we've lived
with whether it was time or place
um or budget in some cases and I think
those constraints are going to go away
and the promise is that if we are
flexible and smart and we use technology
in the right way that will actually come
away a much more evolved and efficient
Workforce
well I think you just showed us some of
the passions that you've talked about as
being the the thing that gives you
energy to to lead that organization of
1300 people worldwide Anjali thank you
so much for being here today thank you
this was great